heading into a very busy sports weekend
t-mobile packed with ufc fans that's
happening tomorrow boy the las vegas
raiders playing at home on sunday
they're taking on the miami dolphins and
if that's not enough it is nascar
weekend and it is happening at the
speedway which is where we find hector
mejia live this afternoon and hector boy
las vegas proving once again that not
only are we the capital of entertainment
but we are also capital of sports
indeed and there's so much going on this
weekend three days of nascar playoff
races here at the speedway in fact and
this will be the first time they'll get
to have full stands in over 18 months
the las vegas motor speedway is
expecting upwards of a hundred thousand
fans through the weekend
no vaccine or mask requirements outside
in the stands a couple of experiences
are coming back this year including neon
garage where fans get to interact with
the drivers well the fans tell us nascar
weekend is all about family time former
las vegas local john han singer flew
back to the valley to meet up with his
son
we've been doing this since he was tiny
and now he's doing with his kids and
it's i mean i just i just flew in last
night from tennessee the best part is
just this just camping and just having a
good time and
we also met a nascar driver las vegas
local matt jaskell he's got quite a
story this will be his first time racing
in nascar professionally he's got a
grand entrance planned for saturday's
race he'll parachute out of a helicopter
from five thousand feet during driver
introductions he'll go straight into the
car to race and it all starts tonight
with the truck race then tomorrow we
have the xfinity series and it all wraps
up with the south point 400 on sunday
reporting live from the las vegas motor
speedway hector mejia live local now